[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати,
Яворів]
Це є унікальне мистецтво.
Таке не роблять ніде у світі, лиш у нас.
А я ткала ще коли маленькою була,
у третому класі я вже ткала.
У мене робив дід з бабою ліжники.
А мама робила так само, бо була мусила. Потім і я.
[Ганна Копильчук
Майстриня-ліжникарка]
Так уже займаюсь 40 років ліжникарством.
Після закінчення школи я постійно цим займаюсь.
Ми в тому росли і ми мусили
вставати та й робити час від часу.
Спершу нас не дуже допускали,
бо ми на стілець лізли та й мішали,
а потім уже змушували працювати.
А ми не дуже хотіли, але...
[сміється]
Під кінець ніде не ділися від цього
свого мистецтва.
Ми вчилися ткати.
Я не зовсім вчилася спеціально цього.
[Наталя Кіщук
Майстриня-ліжникарка]
Це була така робота
як дитяча забавка, захоплення.
Зараз  ми вже при дорозі живемо
коло більшої цивілізації,
а виросла і до семи років, то у горах жила.
Там нема як доїхати машиною.
Та й спілкування було більше з природою.
Коли на обід бабуся йшла їсти варити
чи води носити,
до станка йшла, там й ткала що вміла.
Так мимоволі і навчилася.
Зараз я, наприклад, без цієї роботи не можу.
Це як залежність, та й не знаю.
Кажуть: «Їдь на роботу у Київ,
в Польщу, ще кудись.
Мене це все не захоплює,
бо я рада, що маю улюблене заняття.
Щоб виготовити ліжник, треба мати вівцю.
Овець нема у нас у селі, вовна у нас
уся із Закарпаття. Ми привозимо її.
Коли ту вовну ми помиємо, посушимо,
то вона ось так виглядає.
Суха вовна виглядає ось так, бачте?
Це такі природні кольори вовни:
біла, сіра світла, сіра темна, чорна.
Ще є вовна отака:
художники називають її сичовою.
Бачите, ця вовна дуже від білої відрізняється,
але це також природна вовна.
Коли вівця спить в нечистому місці,
виходить саме така вовна.
Потім вовну сортуємо по кольорах,
тоді відвозимо в чесалку,
Зараз це механізований процес.
Бо раніше воно було усе вручну.
Веретено крутиться ось так:
від мізинця до великого пальця.
Крутиться-крутиться.
Трошки тонше, трошки грубше,
так можна навчитися прясти.
Я вклала ці нитки, тепер цю відпускаю.
А цю кладу тут.
Тут перехрестилося.
Тоді прибиваємо. Потім знову тчемо в інший бік.
Ліжник з верстата.
Отакий «голий».
Таким ліжником ніхто не користується.
Це ще треба давати у валило.
Без валила не можна.
Якби оминути цей етап роботи,
то була б пародія.
Якщо великий ліжник
(півтораспальний, як цей) валяється,
він зсідається на 35-40 сантиметрів.
І ущільнюється, повинен ущільнитися.
Має стати такий тугенький.
Додатково позбувається запаху вівці.
Бо якщо, наприклад, такий неваляний,
то ще той запах шерсті  зберігається.
Його не можеш повністю виполоскати.
А після води уже того запаху нема.
У нас було 13 валил.
У 2008 році прийшла повінь,
лишилось у нас всього одне валило.
Там, де форельне господарство, під скелею.
Оце така дамба.
Таки треба підняти рівень дамби виище,
аби там був спад до валила.
Аби воно крутилося само:
природно, під натиском.
Без ніяких моторів, без нічого.
Все з дерева зробили.
Вода набирається, маса дуже велика,
і воно під тиском само крутить ті ліжники.
І мама, і баба,
[Микола Кіщук
Майстер-ліжникар]
і сестра, і я ткав ліжники також. Усі!
На хороший ліжник потрібно шість годин [валяння].
Він робиться такий гладкий.
А як такий маленький,
то три-чотири години [буде достатньо].
Він розміром у 40 сантиметрів.
Ця вода калатає,
поки не зіб'є його на 40 сантиметрів.
Там такий масаж – спина горить від того.
Мені вже 52 роки, слава Богу.
Як молодий. [сміється]
Це міра. Тут є [позначка] 1,75 метра,
метр вісімдесят, метр дев'яносто.
Господиня знає, який [розмір] їй треба
на двоспальний [ліжник], менший чи більший.
Це метр вісімдесят.
Стандарт на двоспальне ліжко.
О, а це зараз ми беремо,
після того, як розклали,
і кладемо його в центрифугу.
О, і розганяємо.
Ну все, бачте, як воно там уже.
Вся вода зараз по стінках розбігається.
Усе – він уже напівсухий.
Можна на плечі покласти
і понести куди завгодно.
За три години зараз висохне.
Потім беруть
таку грабельку — залізні зубці такі — і начісують її,
поки не відпустить такий ворс великий.
Усе, ліжник готовий!
Кожного дня є робота:
мити, сушити, граблювати —
то вже три дні.
Потім привезти, потім пофарбувати, якщо треба,
натягнути основи й виткати — то є шість днів.
♪ Послухайте, люди добрі, що хочу казати... ♪
Щодо доньки: вона вже вміє,
дуже гарно також тче,
але такі простенькі візерунки, нескладні.
Трохи забирає увагу телефон, інтернет.
Ми так боремося із цим.
♪ Про мистецтво Яворова можу розказати... ♪
Можу сказати, що боролася трошки,
бо батьки не уявляли моє майбутнє у ліжникарстві.
Мама — математика та фізика.
Чоловік так само виростав.
Ліжники у родині так само ткали.
Вчився в Івано-Франківську
і паралельно підзаробляв.
Перший ліжник почав ткати у восьмому класі.
[Ярослав Кіщук
Майстер-ліжникар]
Але вже в дев'ятому класі у мене
було п'ять-шість своїх перших ліжників.
Один із перших ліжників продав за форинти.
Навіть не за гривні, то ще гривні не було.
Ліжники гуцули робили собі здавна,
відколи себе пам'ятали.
Бо тут були умови для тримання овець.
Така мала вівця гуцула годувала,
зодягала, зігрівала.
Бо було м'ясо, був сир з молока,
із шкіри був кожух.
Сердак [сукняний одяг з рукавами]
із сукна з вовни.
Штани у чоловіків також були з вовни.
Пряли тоненьку нитку отаку, наприклад.
Оце отак само прядена ниточка.
Основа вовняна.
Із такої нитки було сукно.
Так тепер називається кашемір.
А з грубої нитки — робили ліжник.
Основа так само була така.
І цим стелили, цим накривалися.
Ліжники були, можна сказати, більш популярні.
У той час, коли зникло все з полиць магазинів.
Коли не було, що купити в подарунок,
то дуже купували одні в подарунок
на весілля молодим,
інші — на день народження родичам.
Та тепер теж дуже популярні ліжники,
просто в нас уже мало робітників.
Це вільна робота.
Можна сказати, що цінність оцієї роботи
вільна в тому, що створюєш орнамент,
тчеш згідно зі своїм настроєм,
зі своєю силою та матеріалами.
Оце виставковий ліжник.
Тут є така справжня Гуцульщина.
Отакі гуцульські були кольори:
і на вишиванках, і на кептарях гуцульських.
У нас є це все в хаті.
І такі ліжники так само були.
Отакий ліжник — в ружі, це один з перших;
цей такий був ліжник немов багатий,
бо хто міг так файно виткати
і зробити з багатьох кольорів.
Не знаю, приїжджають навіть деколи дизайнери.
То і Джамалу одягала,
я вже цим хвалюся тепер,
бо не знала була,
поки мені сусідка не сказала:
«Подивися, вона в такому кожусі,
що ти ткала, бо я точно такого не ткала».
Кажу, що то я ткала,
бо я впізнала свою роботу.
Ну різні історії.
Підіймати собі десь трохи натхнення та й настрій.
Це дуже важливо, бо поки є традиція,
поки є це вміння,
то я думаю, доти ми мали б існувати.
Якщо це все зникне,
то буде зовсім нецікаво жити.
В планшеті, телефоні нема традиції,
це не є традиція, це тепер виникло.
Це теперішнє, виникло недавно.
Це традиція...
Щось там виключиш у космосі —
і ця традиція телефонна пропаде.
Наша традиція не пропаде,
бо веретено вистругав і пішов.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Ліза Литвиненко]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy, BramaDo, Kyiv Ethno Trio]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]